le dit notre cobaye d'art aujourd'hui
tout devrait bien marcher qu'il ya eu
des petits soucis le serveur idron pls
un peu la moitié de l'après midi mais
normalement aujourd'hui à tout
fonctionne bien
y'a pas de nouveaux événements prévus
donc j'ai pu créer le tournoi son
problème
je vous file est le lien je voulais
arriver petit à petit n'hésitez pas à
venir vous êtes la cible ainsi le
tournoi de démarrer à 13h20 montrant
plus d'aujourd'hui
alors en attendant là de petits
américains qui sont en train de sa
mesure 3 +212 remède contre un petit
éléphant qu'il a priori veut préserver
son identité
pour l'instant je vais mc 16 grands
maîtres je t'aime bouliac se sentent pas
très anglo-saxon des bons alors votre
show personne dans le tchat
a priori tout est bien partie pourtant
quand même tiens un truc
incroyable bonjour salue bien d'où ça
venait
salut florian alors je vous mets le lien
déjà si vous êtes chaud pour jouer on
commence dans un petit quart d'heure ça
lui mercier en attendant si vous avez
des questions n'hésitez pas ok cool
c'est toujours le doute éternelle
quant à la technique mais à priori j'ai
toujours agréablement surpris et on va
continuer comme ça ça lui maximus pas
qui était officiellement écoute salade
copains j'ai une petite frustration je
vois mes voisins en train de deux
bronzes tortionnaires de faire leur
jardin depuis ma fenêtre au coeur je
subis je suis presque à ouvrir les
volets ça faisait un petit peu difficile
mais j'ai pas de balcon salut après neuf
ans à l'usap chaix et salue maximus ou
est-ce que vous allez bien vous
apprendra des voisins jouent aux échecs
c'est une solution paquito tu as raison
mais j'ai pas s'ils font très attention
à la pression est toujours beaucoup de
chaises ça se renouvelle en plus pas mal
donc mais du coup je reste méfiant je
vais pas aller jusqu'à les des doucets
départ en 39 45
j'ai demandé tournage par qui tout a
bien anticipé
ok ouais c'est vrai ça c'est clair
voilà exactement la belle époque comme
express salut oui ça ne
rennes gadjé pas trop comment prononce
je pouvais leur demander de de ton dans
la boue de taille et werner aux formes
d'échiquier de faire un truc un peu
artistique s'allume au greffe olaya 44
ici j'ai bien suivi et pas le même au
greffe à l'oeil qui joue là car notre
pseudo
et du coup dur tu es pas intervenu au
mode professeurs pour faire le bal
retraités voisins ah si c'est toi ok
jarriot de la 3° fu lei difficile de
savoir qui est l'unique l'otan de si tôt
question pour un balcon j'ai pas aimé ça
je pense que décrié g4 très fort dira
peut-être ap la police
salut capote masqué il est toujours
présent en dehors ça lui est soumise
futur écoute fab et pas la famille sera
là j'ai pas s'il est là demain soir avec
le futur gros seins avec la fédération
vous prendre ça va y arriver
l'un des wagons pour vous là ça lui qui
m samedi la vie nous a peut-être déjà un
petit peu parlé un truc très sympa qui
se profile au profit de médecins sans
frontières avec mpl etienne bacrot
mathieu carle est fade libye à partir de
19h donc je peux vous serez nombreux
avant les championnats de france des
clubs qui va se lancer et demeurait tout
c'est un sketch pense à marennes de la
fédération n'y a pas besoin d'avoir une
licence on se pare en tout cas a priori
l'idée ces jeux libres et du coup je
voudrais juste peut-être dans le club
français ou quelque chose comme ça mais
alors je regarde un petit peu les
inscrits pour l'instant et encore pas
grand monde apprendre à attendre comme
dans une scène de minutes
nb l'ultra favori ah oui toujours
après gavin on sait jamais un peu
surpris s'il va jouer avec fab
c'est a priori c'est pas spécialement un
avantage de jouer à deux mais cette
embrouille plus qu'autre chose
ok pas qui tu aimes tu confirmes c'est
qu'il n'y a pas besoin de licence pour
jouer demain donc n'hésitez pas à venir
nombreux le risque darren toute façon à
13 heures comme d'habitude
et en plus le soir un petit peu de rab
je sais pas si on a des trucs à gagner
de voiliers des récompenses chance à
rien et guillaume maintenant je ne vais
pas jouer après peut-être qu'une fois
pourrait jouer aussi ce sera sur tweets
certainement maximus pour commenter mes
parties la lidc plus de deux pouvoirs
votre jouet bras droit de dire des gros
mots paquito d'un kg est pas l'habitude
mais j'imagine que ce sera pareil alors
pour l'instant ça commence à bien se
remplir vous êtes vingtaine ça arrive
assez vite je vois maugrée paul qui
caracole en tête des inscrits elle
devrait avoir des concurrents de choix
bientôt et salut à l'extérieur je vous
aime bien fou il joue en 30 secondes les
mecs donc là ils sont très très chaud
c'est fait social sain il est toujours
présent les joues contre un moment m un
tiens tiens hommage à gandhi avec under
cover douteux je sais pas trop on met 30
secondes ça l'à beaucoup trop envie de
là c'est un commun table pour le coup et
salue manuvie gars à vue vient à lui le
gaffeur budget je sais pas si vous avez
déjà pu essayer de jouer à cette cadence
de 30 secondes carreau est ce que ça
vous inspire
moi j'aime mieux ça sera vrai chic et
c'est à dire voir les pièces volées par
tous même les pièces très mal ce sont
les 15 juillet sur la pendule qui par
terre dit que dawn askham 24 heures de
ce très bon staff bravo assez
impressionnant non-stop en est on à
bobby fischer qui arrive très chaud pour
gagner l'aréna ouais vous préférez les
cadences un petit peu plus longue sur un
vrai chic et à l'écouté show spectacle
même les gens qui savent pas je vais
d'une plus regardent avec des yeux on
peut et marie mai à 30 secondes c'est
extrême moi je ne le fais pas je préfère
comme le huit minutes plus classiquement
moi aussi j'ai c'est d'être défendu par
le gaffeur légère et ça lui prendra pas
on met un petit coup de liens je vois
dont j'ai l'habitude moi ça m'a toujours
manqué volaille
j'ai le meilleur et l'eau objectif du
jour battre baky taux monte à qui tout
est là dans l'esprit en tout cas pour se
laisser battre a priori seul ngage salut
à yaoundé sixty nine 9g pas pourquoi je
le dis en anglais mais ça m'inspire
davantage à criquetot film en coucou
eyes alors big fish dans ce match pour
l'instant et manu 17 mai quatre et demi
mais du coup pas ridicule au jo j'ai
déjà joué une fois contre bigs fille
juste en 3d de dante harper s'était bien
passé d'ailleurs pour moi salut marques
ou les premiers iam des 16 à 9
quelle idée cacher derrière ce moment
salut qu'à pita tort le mans alors qu'on
commence dans sept minutes salut marcico
par khune troisième maillot pour
l'instant on va voir si ça reste le cas
déjà une trentaine de joueurs mais les
gens s'inscrivent petit à petit sa luge
et m j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des
duels gens qui aiment bien se trouvait
alors
sm savait pas encore de votre départ
mais bon sur internet les parties
longues ou longues comme en classe eco
bat ça se fait pas trop de gens
s'ennuient au tout début quand même de
partir en 2006 l'américain davantage
réfléchir proposer posé plein de
questions avant de choisir un coup au
prophète eut commis trop d'erreurs
tactiques saluer le barda russe à l'ue
pour le dégage du coup et donc tu
connais encore pas mal d'erreurs
tactiques que tu as besoin de tout
vérifier dans les positions les pièces
en crise
les fourchettes les enfilades vis-à-vis
ça prend du temps de le faire un peu à
chaque coup d'éclat pièces comme moi
c'est un petit peu à s'activer ensemble
donc je pense que dix minutes c'est bien
après prend plus de plaisir à je vais
peut-être en partie public non à l'or
fin des 90's 8100 je ne conseille pas du
tout posséder ouverture pour l'instant
la tactique te fera gagner beaucoup plus
de partis parce qu'en fait apprendre des
trucs parker ça sert vraiment à rien au
début l'idée c'est de mieux comprendre
il ya tellement de choses à essayer de
comprendre déchets que je veux tellement
riche et profond c'est vraiment la
stratégie et surtout les tactiques parce
que c'est vrai que les parties elles se
jouent toujours sur une erreur tactique
c'est un peu le dernier qui fait une
boulette qui va perdre surtout à ce
niveau là donc les ouvertures dans la
viande plus tard donc vraiment n'hésitez
pas il ya plein de les exos tas qui sont
bien sûr de chasse comme en plus vous
pouvez sélectionner un peule et m
et toi qui est presque 1400 le gaffeur
déjà les leçons peuvent être sympa sur
jazz ka mois ci alors pas les premiers
niveaux du coup forcément oui je vais la
plupart mais je pense sincèrement parce
qu'il ya pas mal de thèmes stratégiques
on commence à avoir des et qui sont
intéressants après 1400 faire beaucoup
d'exercices tactique c'est très bien
aussi
ça c'est les hommes chose si vous prenez
pas l'entraîneur à traire d'entraîneur à
quelqu'un qui va vous guider qui l'a
repéré tout de suite un peu vos
faiblesses sur quoi travailler et comme
pour toi pour la musique on importe
lequel discipline c'est axel raix un
grand mot votre votre progression
d'avoir quelqu'un qui a un regard à vous
éclairer
mais juste pour y ait plus de parti et
déjà des tactiques bosser les calculs
ont progressé bien peser leur âge pour
1500 en ce moment je suis pas sûr de
bien décrypter la question pensent
qu'ils étaient 2 et la vache
moi je trouve ça veut dire que j'aime
bien refaire le défaut c'est je trouve
que bas les laiteries trois billets 20
premiers souvent peut-être un peu
grossier alors que les justes les
problèmes si vous avez l'on voulait
problème vous pouvez sélectionner les
thèmes élimination du défenseur
surcharge des choses qu'on retrouve
souvent au parti c'est davantage ciblés
et vous pouvez aussi choisir une
fourchette lots donc ça vous corresponde
à votre niveau de difficulté je pense à
mieux que les problèmes et ben écoute 16
pour un début c'est pas si mal non
pour et scorer par exemple après on a pu
voir que des trucs bizarres on peut ce
match par exemple les tous meilleurs au
monde c'est d'un tout petit peu de
shopping truc là ce n'étaient pas les
plus paranos maxime il avait participé
au championnat puzzle rasch et je sais
plus qui l'avait éliminée mais c'est un
mec bien moins fort mais qui lui faisait
un score astronomique mais il faisait
que ça c'est vraiment une gymnastique du
cerveau très particulière à laquelle se
sont traîné ce programme et fait 45
minutes bobby fischer ok mon record je
crois que c'est 45 francs déjà tu passe
la barre des 30 c pas mal on a un
premier palier et après les quarante
souvent la difficulté se corse ce grand
beaucoup un côté un petit peu études
donc là c'est quand même l'instinct qui
fait qui fait la différence
maxime 57 c'est possible j'ai pu le les
scores d'être exacts mais déjà dépassé
les 50 c est le plus impressionnant moi
je trouve que 4 ans et n a évidemment
qu'il faisait ça en écoutant de la
musique en discutant avec les gens on
regarde au plafond et puis à chaque fois
il faisait ça comme ça que je dois
trouver quoi
des mots des inscrits toujours mangue la
volaille quelle étiquette de favori mais
pas un rôle tout en face et leurs hauts
de seine alors quand même quelques
quelques challengers ont rejoint la
compétition à l'amicale h 38 sauf erreur
du spectacle je le connais bien
elle devrait pas une belle est pour
l'instant quarantaine de joueurs saluent
cyril of watch appelle d'ici et
d'ailleurs on va commencer d'ici
quelques secondes avec l'homme l'homme
trotters a fait 45 arabes ont bien tu
qu'on va arrêter de se brûler les yeux
avec avec le 30 ce groupe là ça va
beaucoup trop vite et on va voir ça
devrait se passer d'une seconde à
l'autre
wade en seconde ok alors c'est bien de
se fixer de petits objectifs perso
iam je réponds c'est à dire la suite
ouais si tu peut gratter les 1800
pourquoi pas
du coup on va peut-être je le promets
racheter dans un premier temps puis reçu
de jeu serait de regarder un peu pour
monde
et du coup la première partie ces
mauvais fallen contre cirilo qui
s'adresse crible in extremis alors
mauvaise foi laïque ya les noirs il a
opté pour quelque chose d'assez rare aux
environs de 14 très rapidement sur
l'espagnol c'est certainement pas une
grande variante du coup ça l'air de
perturber un petit peu son adversaire
qui direct je vais réfléchir
bush et qu'il avait déjà joué un truc
comme servent aussi mais ce n'était pas
très bien passée dans une prépa
supertramp john je m'étais un peu fait
réfléter alors lié aux syndicats un
niveau espéré atteindre 1,13 en passant
trois heures par jour
alors c'est assez difficile de répondre
comme ça parce que comme aussi pour
toute activité on a des prédispositions
plus ou moins 20 pour les échecs ou non
donc selon si tu veux à des capacités
battu progressera plus vite tu verras
plus haut mais déjà si tu poses 3 1 par
jour de toute façon les 13 ans est
encore très jeune un tas de la barre
progressait bah je sais pas mais 2007
devrait pas poser dans l'amont problème
c'est vraiment motivés et salue le futur
après raisons d'être fier d'eux aussi
c'est pas du tout est inaccessible et
ensuite à partir de grands maîtres même
déjà maître international dans sa
demande
juste de travail l'investissement plus
de talent tout dépend de comment tuer en
rayon tnt reste assez four
difficile de dire jusqu'où quelqu'un pas
monter avant même qu'elle ait commencé
sa lutte futur toujours en rendez vous
le futur
il est très content il y parle fort et a
le droit tolère les majuscules taille de
bottes ça va du coup la partie pour
l'instant j'avais bien que c'est
relativement symétrique le match donc
les noirs ont joué f5
ça change un petit peu le caractère de
la position alors fkl pas une menace
encore parce que le foie toujours
d'échappatoire il sera assis mal dans
cette grande diagonale d'ailleurs fous
ces 5 et 6 ans qui fait sens voit que
les blancs ont un petit peu plus d
espaces riches ou faux c'est 5 cyril où
je pense que ça vient je vais y crée des
problèmes pratiques avec le clouage et
les pièces déplacement se marche un peu
les unes sur les autres
mais y avoir des petites tensions au
simple option mais ça peut se retrouver
faible après l'ouverture de la colonne
municipaux cannois fasse attention après
une idée ça peut être parfois de tout
fermer pour lancer une attaque sur le
droit mais pas ainsi que c'est un peu
lourd et avec l'accolade dé ouverte
je pense que les blancs autant d'en
profiter
lorena jeu leron à la cheville qui a un
petit coup prophylactique est toujours
utile on s'enlève de cette diagonale
dangereuse on pourra toujours se prendre
des échecs amoureux
une tactique une variante qui serait
fatal perso j'aurais peut-être me
laurent achète je sais pas c'est
toujours une question difficile parfois
on perd beaucoup de temps contre 17 sur
un petit coup vers le meilleur 10
avouent prendre une décision il n'y a
pas une grande différence
je pense maintenant le pont pousserait
des caïds c4 et on va mettre une
pression sur le kiosque alors l'ua
préfère mettre sont fausses et 4
pourquoi pas il a interdit le fouloir de
venir au le 6 pour libérer un peu la
tour où pour l'instant gérer que mandela
fallait il est sous pression avec les
noirs mais à la position reste très
ouverte
alors le lien pour le club hac par ici
donné ça
la capote masqué qui nous dit qu'il a 15
ans ça fait trois mois qu'il fait des
échecs nous on combien de temps tu peux
attendre 2000 et l'officier de non
encore une fois j'ai assisté à ce que
j'étais l'ordre font ça va vraiment
dépendre d'eux des prédispositions et
des joueurs qui connaissent une
progression fulgurante c'est à dire que
en bout sans intensivement en un nom ils
sont capables de monter à 2000 dans
l'absolu d'autres pour qui ce sera plus
laborieux et mettront juste pas cinq ans
d'autres même peut-être dix ans et
d'autres qu'ils n'y arriveront jamais
parce que pour une raison ou une autre
je sais vraiment pas de facilités par
exemple pour le calcul ils ont beaucoup
de mal à se projeter ya la géométrie
spatiale qui peut poser problème pour
certaines personnes font régulièrement
des erreurs de calcul donc une
fourchette entre 1 et 5 ans où je dirais
si vraiment tu obtiens à ce rythme de
travail
ouais ont travaillé cinq ans la capote
masqué alors qu'ils ne le comble et
lougheed ballet lougheed en fait
jack poole et l'ozone feed c'est juste
un système de placement par exemple au
tennis bat les joueurs ont des points
il marque des points quand il ya des
tendances d'échec c'est pareil on va
répondre quand on gagne les parties du
coup on a un certain nombre de points
quand on bombarde adversaire qui a son
classement en gagnant deux moyens quand
on va voir beaucoup plus fort que nous
gagne le max de points et quand on perd
contre 1 de ma forme
car le le max de points aussi au créneau
c'est juste un nombre qui nous permet
d'avoir notre idée du niveau d'un joueur
en sachant qu'au départ selon un sondage
tu vas commencer avec lots de base entre
1000 et 1499 ça va changer quand tu es
adulte
alors pour apprendre à visualiser
l'échiquier quoi retards d'impôts la
meilleure chose à faire c'est juste de
faire des tactiques en fait tu es là tu
peux t'entraîner à le faire en fermant
les yeux c'est à dire tu mets la
position de base tu poses le problème
juste imprègne bien de chaque pièce et
surtout tu touche pas les pièces sur
l'échiquier même si tu pense avoir
trouvé la solution tu te force à ne pas
jouer les coups et a calculé jusqu'au
bout les variantes sommes certains il ya
toile et les gros joueurs souvent il
regarde en l'air
la remarque est sceptique ou parfois on
regarde c'est bon ça on a les yeux dans
le vague
on peut aussi fermé les yeux ça peut
être un moyen de concentrer davantage
pourront visualiser les positions et le
vélo il change tous les mois
ah ok ça a changé cette année c'est 1199
d'accord et shine on forme il l'a fait
ok de mon temps quand j'ai commencé les
adultes commencé à 1499 pensais que
c'était assez élevés souvent bas il perd
des plans de pont 1976 comme ça commence
à être pas mal du tout achever iata
carrément moyens ont déjà deux de faire
de belles parties des perfs
viser plus loin aux maîtres c'est clair
bon dieu va du potentiel ici alors les
grands joueurs arrivent à calculer
combien de coups la notion de calcul va
dépendre aussi de la simplicité d'une
position où nous dire plus le matériel
est réduit plus c'est facile de calculer
par exemple c'est très facile de
calculer une course d'options qui a plus
que les rois élections bart en compte
les temps pour aller à dame pourra les
rattraper coupe du monde
là c'est presque élémentaires aux
fournisseurs et qu'il ya toutes les
pièces sur l'échiquier la difficulté est
là les ide donc tous les arbres c'est à
dire qu'à chaque coup mais un nouvel
arbre qui se créent deux variantes
possibles pour ton adversaire donc qui
doit pas calculer une seule variante
mais plein de possibilités donc là tu
peux facilement semelle rouge et dans
les différentes variantes donc mais
souvent ils peuvent calculer mais une
dizaine de coups même dans ses positions
là mais ils sont pas à l'abri du cou
d'un gros oubli tactique aussi de temps
en temps il se fit aussi davantage
parfois à leur intuition alors en
promotion inné de la position on sait
que bien souvent on dire tiens je sais
que ce goût appartient à la position de
cette pièce elle à partir à cette quatre
places et pas de calcul juste a ressenti
parce que payet une forme d'évidence que
la boîte gaz pour telle pièce c'est
celle ci ou donc celle là wen avait
entendu dire qu'elle veut capter 15
coups seulement c'est pas souvent mais
c'est reparti voix c'est exactement ça
c'est vraiment dans des cas extrêmes
peut-être plus originales parfois pour
des courses de deux pions le premier qui
arrive à dar ben quoi moi j'avais je
compterai nouvelle quand il était petit
un championnat de france jeunes il est
déjà tard confort qu'ils étaient rentes
ont surclassé c'est à dire que j'y
jouais avec les moins de 16 ans alors
qu'il avait seulement 12 ans mais ça n'a
aucun intérêt pour mieux de jouer avec
les douze ans allemands
il dominait déjà il était haut comme
trois pommes
j'avais joué contre lui du coup j'avais
perdu et j'avais été vraiment très
impressionnant mais c'était à l'analyse
c'est à dire que mon pendant la partie
je n'étais pas si mal défendu et devait
sortir le sacrifice de pièces brillant
juste juste pour des compensations
positionnelle donc c'était assez mal
passé pour moi finalement après un début
plutôt prometteur et à l'analyse en fait
donc il était vraiment tout petits à la
gordie sur les tarmacs signe plutôt nous
était assez impressionnant de voir un
enfant de cet âge d'éviter des variantes
d'une dizaine de coups à un rythme
effréné en fait je les ai quand même
plutôt dans les bons gènes on va dire
dans les dix meilleurs lots de ma
catégorie d'âge
j'étais censé comprendre à peu près ce
qui se passait mais juste maximiser
voulait complètement sur une autre
planète et donc il est avec son
entraîneur je me rappelle il se regarde
et moi j'étais vraiment espérer une
partenaire j'ai regardé député de
l'ariège ou qui soumet les pièces les
couches sur l'échiquier et je comprenais
pas trop ce qui se passait c'est un peu
la leçon et du coup déjà je présume
qu'il irait très très loin et donc oui
j'ai bien sûr les calculs 15 brin coup
pour lui c'est là pour le coup c'est de
l'ordre de l'ine or even facilité en
calcul exceptionnelle c'est peut-être le
joueur qui calcule le mur d'un maximum
je pense
la cadence est venue trois plus de
dégage d'avoir quatre ans de plus que
maxime jordan et donc oui à zoom du coup
il va voir aux autres mois il avait déjà
2300 peut-être 80 à quelque chose comme
ça il avait été champion de france des
minimes donc 90 fiction d'agir
ça lui a caché ben écoute ça va bien et
toi ce que tu joues ce tournoi ouais
c'est assez incroyable mais j'étais
vraiment j j'avais joué contre un autre
joueur qui était assez fort qui est
devenu à ses forces étaient meilleurs la
bourlingue georges meyer vous voyez
peut-être souvent au petit c est lui
j'avais je compte lui je sentais qu'il
est de venir forme aussi alors qu'il
avait entre guillemets que 1900 à
l'époque il est devenu quand même
presque deux mille sept cents mais
c'était beaucoup moins impressionnant
que maxime est d'ailleurs on voit que je
suis appartiennent pas encore du tout à
la même planète aussi parce que je vois
qu'on va parler de 1800 et ceux qui sont
aux alentours des 2700 il ya une grande
différence malgré tout et bah oui en ce
moment c'est sûr que c'est marie dit le
grand espoir français mais il est encore
jeune donc c'est difficile de savoir
jusqu'où il va aller c'est évident qu'il
est très talentueux le rock un poil à
devenir maître par contre après sept
jours de se rendre compte ça dépend
aussi de plein de choses de parcours de
vie pour devenir un joueur de top niveau
peut-être mal boyer nous dit petit poney
je sais pas trop mal c'est un joueur
talentueux c'est sûr je sais pas quel
âge il a exactement mais elle est très
sympa en plus la bande heures dans des
positions 8e il peut faire patte
j'ai été témoin direct de ça n'est pas
très longtemps par équipes
il avait une dame folle la dame femmes
pour ceux qui connaissent pas c'est en
fait nous reste plus que 1 3 et notre
dame et de notre adversaire un gros
avantage matériel donc en gros on est
foutu mais nos trois en situation de pat
donc il aurait pu juste faire des échecs
un filet avec la dame pour forcer la
pour france l annuler oui dollars 15 ou
16 ans mais j puce pas joué contre lui
mais le voir jouer plusieurs fois et
c'est sûr que là du potentiel mais déjà
il est en retard par rapport à tous les
petits gardiens sur d'eau et donc mais
vous n'avez pas déjà qu'ils ne peut pas
aller ensuite les différents rythmes de
progression ça dépend de plein de choses
à chêne bourg concentre un peu sur une
partie malgré tout la tuture justement
en train de jouer contre hikaru kama
sutra il fut assuré john faire une dame
donc là c'est la bonne nouvelle pour lui
est ce qui se passe il a pas le pion
d'être promu le tube était juste trop
fort du coup de prague est son problème
alors elle se relancer vers une partie
un peu plus équilibré je veux regarder
paquito mais s'était terminée donc là
donc paquito avec les bleus ont débuté
en début de partie après ce qui s'est
passé avec scottish contre salt i et
pitau qui prend les spasmes dahleb
lambres d'y jouer avec les blonds clara
beaucoup pour l'initiative
j'aime beaucoup sa position fait on voit
que les noirs sont quand même très
passive sont restreints sur seulement
leurs deux premières rangées leblanc ont
énormément d'espacé ou un centre très
fort donc le ça présage une partie
difficile je pense pour ça aussi on va
voir comment ça évolue et dont la partie
la roue tourne et il découvre assez
logique des 5 c'est bien de jouer
évidemment le
le rêve c'est de jouer tessier 50 on
peut avoir un fond pas assez protégé en
plein coeur de la position inverse pour
une très grosse épine du pied et du coup
il est parvenu le font plus effet
enfermés watch quatre d'échappatoire
donc j'ai du coup de donation est sain
et que la position apparemment écrasant
pour à quito qui fait le job alors ici
la carte et un petit fou le set
et tout ça pour gagner la tour descoings
scène et on entendait on en est là
l'heure perdue en tueur malgré tout un
pion à égalité matérielle mais il ya la
paire de fou et surtout et un centre
surpuissant des cullen ouverte mais vous
qu'ils fassent un peu attention les
atouts sont rois dans les courants d'air
sur quatre même si objectivement c'est
très bien pour pour les blancs restent
prendre une fourchette
il peut s'en sortir par dame détroit
parce que sur gap des 3 si jamais le
cavalier mouche la tour on est sauvé en
mangeant madame grâce au cloud à cette
dame qui est pas vraiment défendu
finalement on gtx donc la fourchette ici
rendu 4 ne fonctionne pas grâce à dame
détroit on va voir si le devoir oui bah
ouais 10 à un pur produit de l'école
corse
alors du coup on j'analyse s'accouplent
salle comble direct une bonne question
[Musique]
11 à un parti c'est parce qu'il s'est
passé vraiment ça en fait ils n'auraient
pas tout ça d'hommes seuls ti ça c'est
triste pour lui que j'ai réfléchi est-ce
que rien du tout il pu faire le
cavaliere trois échecs mais récupérera
pas assez de ma taille peut manger le
fou les finis connaît qu'une dame 2 - en
ski si je parierais déchets abandonnés
ou je sais pas trop je n'aime pas trop
c'est une arène il faut quand même
essayer de d'enchaîner les parties dont
quand on est foutu le mieux c'est
d'abandonner de passer à la suivante
[Musique]
et ont l'impression que si problèmes de
connexion sur cette partie c'est pas
trop quoi alors on a changé de parti on
va les voir qu'à l'acheter et là il ya
une balade du roi
voici sais pas comment il s'est retrouvé
là mais c'est une finale de dame ouest
après je les ai un peu changé pour le
dga je vais regarder des je crois que
d'autres niveaux
est-ce qui est bientôt les finales de
roi en fait c'est que des finales de
dames pardon c'est que nos 3 c'est pas
si se balade ou en plein milieu
l'échiquier parce que vos piris prendre
à des échecs sera harceler donc dans le
pire des cas il y aura un perpétuel
mais ici le budget se trouver un abri de
se mettre derrière lampions et ici
sic a lâché la gagne deux points ou plus
donc normalement cette finale dames
elle devra gagner sans problème la sita
petit surcroît c'est bien sûr balade à
travers échiquier il devrait trouver un
abri tranquillement derrière cette
chaude et ensuite normalement il y aura
plus qu avant ses deux pions des en
finale b dames chose qui n'a pas entendu
aussi à savoir c'est que bon nombre
d'options mais pas si important on peut
avoir deux trois points gagnants si
c'est vraiment d'avoir l'union le plus
avancé
c'est une course on va essayer de
l'escorté avec notre dame
quand on a contrait projet adam même si
on en a plein en moins on sera favoris
pour la victoire en finale de la l'autre
facteur très important c'est la sécurité
du roi parce qu'il ya souvent des
chèques perpétuelle qui traînent salut
arty égard flaugnac alors il prend son
temps avec les blancs une peine un petit
peu a progressé mais normalement ça
irait pour plancher la marge du pion ou
encore mieux la mise à terme sur la
mauvaise case est permis l'échangé
d'arbres maintenant fiscal droit
d'option de plus ça va tout seul et donc
là il devrait avoir aucun problème
un terminé la partie des kalachs et des
16 à 9 qui a pour objectif je crois
c'est lui qui voulait garder la 1800 à
la fin du tournoi il va les perdre sur
cette partie bon ca à croire qu'à nous
deux parties je peux regarder non
c'était des questions n'hésitez pas
presque regardé une partie peut-être
opus est parfait qui commentent juste
entre deux joueurs un peu moins bien
classés lucien contre akinator alors
ok mais pour l'instant c'est juste de la
théorie mais les noix ses imposants
l'option de manger de pioncer 4 isolé en
d4
s'il a décidé de donner la paire de
croquer une position assez standard mais
pour l'instant les noirs sont plutôt
bien sortis il ya certes la paire de fou
pour les plans mais c'est pas très grave
ils ont une structure très solide ils
ont une légère annonce développement on
voit déjà à l'abri et on va peut-être
potentiellement gagner un pion même si
on n'est pas du tout sûr de le conserver
jusqu'au bout ce qu'on sait qu'à part
c'est dommage qu'il aurait vraiment pu
manger on sait 4 profiter du courage
pourquoi pas ensuite c'est de consolider
ce pont de plus en jambes est simple il
faut réussir sa ceinture
en fait je passe en bonne analyse et je
vois plus dès que je jouais une variante
fait je vois plus les cours en direct je
sais pas du tout comment ça se fait je
sais que mon compte a subi un réglage
hier que personne à l'isem mieux mais on
dirait que c'est l'inversé qui se
produisait pour être pas que je j'ai
intercale deux variantes je sais pas
trop pourquoi
[Musique]
parce que du coup la partie ensuite
saint-vaize chic et l'analyse
je vois plus l'écran ciotti très bizarre
[Musique]
plus du tout l'évolution de la partie
donc je vais essayer juste d'arrêter de
jouer des variantes de résoudre le
problème la prochaine fois juste de vous
montrer un peu les steaks les flashs en
attendant une partie sur partir sur
autre chose et même plus jouer le coup
on ne peut pas faire exploser le serveur
qui est un petit peu capricieux du coin
c'est un chien donc par sur wawa noue
entre eux
angry dad congrès négocient qui très
souvent on sait à rennes du midi serait
alors est ce que ça donne cette position
on a une égalité matérielle
les plans à trois contre deux allèles
dame potentiellement il peut y avoir une
attaque de majorité sur le long terme de
créer un fonds passé si près de la
colonne l'abolition relativement
relativement équilibré ici un peu fou
fait pas grand chose dans cette
diagonale il a un peu dominé par par les
structures de cloud en des fois il veut
garder ce legs à base de vous prendre 6
pour l'instant c'est loin de marcher
mais cannes que les noirs demeurent
attentifs maintenant par exemple ce
genre de thème peut devenir intéressant
avec une idée de fourchette à la fin
sauf que qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a
juste donné son cavalier en un coup
waouh c'est la boulette
le canard le cas là on a profité cash
alors qu'à bac 2 mais bon maintenant et
qu'une pièce de moi ça paraît quand même
très compliqué là c'est vraiment le
genre d'abord dans vos parties vous
forciez à à tout vérifier
ainsi qu'après priori n'y a pas de
retour en arrière possible
en fait jean dard c'est bien compliqué
tu coules ici avec les blancs vous avez
un gros avantage matériel sans
compensation vraiment jouer simple au
solide essayé d'échanger des places au
maximum est un petit pic manger car tu
sais juste pas nécessaire voilà il
s'envoie en l'air avec les bancs et de
tenter le tout pour le tout mais mais
finalement il accentue ses problèmes une
plongée 4les prenable à cause du clonage
donc donc il n'a pas vu qu'elle est
proche et 4 c'est pas grave
reste bien sûr ou platement gayant et
que sa pièce de plus avec les noirs
alors ici peut-être n'ont-ils pas grand
chose à faire en fait on pourrait
abandonner one où je pensais passer à la
partie suivante et aucune perspective d'
attaque réelle
le roi noir hyperdub protéger et oui
même si je trouve le gaffeur fou je
serai peut-être le voir ok là je crois
que c'est beaucoup de grâce pour aux
anneaux qui ajuste de désagréments d'un
coup alors le gars for food charge tombe
pile dessus donc on va aller le voir
il a les noirs contre kk onctueux très
joli match
la position elle plutôt très plate pour
l'instant quand on a été échangé juste
là colonna qui est ouverte mais c'est
pas un problème au pire le punir en 26
la cavalerie cas c'est plutôt bien joué
mais ces deux projets se fout six corps
étaient intéressants je pense ça vous
comme cavalier des 5 ou essayer de
casser la structure du roi adverse d'où
vient d'ouvrir à part
alors les pièces vont s'échanger est ce
qu un siècle et n'ont intérêt à jouer
simple je pense qu'on va éviter comme de
ce fer détériorées note rock ou v5 est
toujours utile laisse faire le premier
cas la structure va être catastrophe
découvert ensuite mangé rond c'est
simple on va tout est changé on va jouer
une finale deux tours avec les blancs
qui va être juste très agréable à
formant geste faut pas hésiter notre
cavalier 24 il est venu là que pour
empocher le fou le fameux cavaliers qu'à
la liane d'elle quand on a l'opportunité
de les changer mais très heureux
maintenant si on a six qui auront à c
est un intérêt dans sa voix à 6000 à
devenir une cible ici beaucoup pour les
blancs sort est discrète je veux tout
race afin de mettre la pression pour
doubler les tours efficace et bien joué
aussi
maintenant c'est plus qu'une affaire de
technique pour cacau monsieur qui
peut-être faire une petite bière faible
gaffard fouka 300 points de plus alors
qu'elle s'implique mentionné rare n'a
aucun intérêt à fermer cette colonne
puisque si on a les marchés actions
alors été ouverte pour notre tour on
sait très bien jouer s'ils jouent tour à
6 avec les noirs fallait à tout prix
éviter ce faire fixer dans la colonne à
la torah 6 en fait il déçu ce qu'on
empêche le pont d'alleyras action recule
voilà comme vient de le faire à deux
battants il ya à 5
et du coup la tour peut se décharger de
cette tâche de défendre le droit à une
pièce lourd d'une tour son rôle fait pas
défendre un vulgaire pion typiquement et
on voit que du beau gamecube il bégaie
un petit peu là et après avec quatre
enchères elle aurait dû justement j'ai
beau champion est simple pour ouvrir la
colonne est mettre une pression sur les
faiblesses en fait la chose à faire la
question à vous poser dans vos parties
s'est identifié les faiblesses
identifier les faiblesses de
l'adversaire et ensuite tout simplement
les attaques à mettre la pression de
cheveux chasser les défenseurs et là
maintenant et cannois il a réussi à
ravir sa consolider le pion raquette
et très bien protégé le pion mef les
deux shows à redoubler qui a été fait
c'est la colonne s'ouvrait son bateau à
la bride parce que la colonne des fermes
et donc ici avec les noix l'orage est
passé
du coup du coup maintenant la position
est très ferme et s'oriente plus vers la
2 mais je pense que les noirs petit à
petit sans pleuve en tournée mais c'est
peut-être d'en voir plus elle croyait me
siècle est bon c'est qu'on n'a plus
aucune perception ce qui va ouvrir les
positions c'est une percée quelconque
mais là ça nous a fait pire est plus
qu'autre chose on se retrouve avec des
pions faible et noir ont eu leur
objectif c'est de jouer h4 pour essayer
de rentrer une tour ou g2 sauf que la
menace est évidemment assez faible dans
le centre soit tout moment les plans
pourront fermer complètement la position
alors on s'est bloqué d'avoir cerné de
juin fait un peu preuve d'imagination
mais si je vois aucun moyen de
déverrouiller cette position à part du
c3 b4 mais je pense qu'en fait celui qui
veut essayer de forcer le gain est de se
retrouver barnes assez typique au dessus
dans les positions ça n'arrivait pas
contraints de jouer un présumé plus
faible vouloir gagner un prix bas des
fois on gagne à tout prix on prend le
risque de perdre savoir si on veut se
contenter de la nulle ou ont-elles tout
pour le tout
et si je pense que cadieux et il est
très content avec l'annuel c'est
peut-être les noix qui vont essayer
davantage les finales de double tour
avec les lions ont quand même assez
souvent ils sont libres et surtout dans
une position ferme et comme celle-ci et
tours ont du mal à s'exprimer
c'est qu'une seule des places c'est
facile de la protéger pour chaque camp a
les mêmes yeux plongés 3 qui est
attaquable et du coup on n'a aucun
problème à l'euro à côté donc les
joueurs un peu tourner en rond tels que
ça va se décider tout simplement quand
ils seront plus trop de temps peut-être
essayer de rentrer amendé sur la colonne
des en sacrifiant ses 4 sauf que pour ce
faire il devra jouer les 50 jours et il
y aura cinq israël il a pu engranger 5
mais le problème c'est que normalement
le roi noir pourra jamais passer mais
petit à petit du terrain malgré tout le
gaffeur fou ça reste très solide pour
les blancs on sait jamais le danger ici
avec les miens c'est d'être vraiment
trop facile d'être aux jeux pour la
bulle du coup de finir par perdre là ils
continuent de progresser un petit peu à
quatre c'est bien la tête réussir à
ouvrir une collab madonia c4 c4 et à il
a raté les noirs prennent l avantage du
galet ce couloir et du coup le cloud
attaqué trois fois
maintenant ils prennent c'est qu'il a
sacrifié un tour ils le récupèrent plus
ça à nouveau tourné et les blancs et
leurs pions plus devraient être ceux qui
pressent
alors je passais tous en train de noël
mais vous parlez plus vous devez vous
concentrer sur vos parts tiennent au
québe 5
encore une fois joué sur le grand âge
playa plusieurs erreurs des deux côtés
c'est la finale techniquement est loin
d'être parfaite
après c'est normal les récupérer son
option on se retrouvera nous a guidé ma
taille je vois bien les douars gagner
parce que si jamais amené le roi arriva
à sainte-luce tél le chômage va tomber
le pion à cheval extrêmement dangereuse
donc du coup cette tour à un peu vous ai
appelé seront maintenant le danger c'est
que la tournoi elle s'infiltre est là l
iam auger le curage 324 pour les mains
servent une très grande force dans cette
finale et petit à petit les plans sont
en train de perdre le fil on puisse en
plus que 10 secondes
car monsieur quitte en souffrance mais à
quel point je sais pas trop ce qui fait
reculer ses atours là j'ai pas compris
la taxe le pion en fait il n'a pas
identifié que voilà ci-dessous h3c lui
qu'il faut attaquer le magpie orages qui
peut nous apporter la victoire ici avec
les noirs voilà enfin
enfin il joue tour des 3 et du coup 48e
ben c'est la petite gastro qui se
profile le look 100 pour lui le courage
devient juste une heure a été appelée
ciel et donc le gaffeur fou va finir par
gagner cette finale
après gagnent beaucoup d'efforts ça
aurait été très compliqué on est juste à
pousser les pions marché assez facile
mais de la tour devant ici honnêtement
j'ai alors il donne le pion m6 du coup
nouveau revirement de situation gbagbo
je pense que ça doit être nul parce que
jusque option être va lui aussi courir
très vite donc la normale et deux tours
ont sacrifié sur les deux
donc c'est toujours de rester en bons
termes après quand même pas mal de
retournement de 2go terre et salut au
grand maître gims du couple c'est
typiquement chaque joueur a une tour à
chaque concours de son côté n'a pas
d'autre choix que de sacrifier notre
tour où habitait la dame avec le roi qui
soutient l'action et du coup ça se
termine tranquillement par là nul donc
les deux joueurs voient leurs chances à
tour de rôle ici après les finales
c'était quelque chose quand même de très
technique le final de tourner ça
s'étudie ça se travaille
le meilleur conseil que je peux vous
donner c'est là mon activité autant
pourvoi 3 que pour 20 tours ne pas jouer
des coups passif ne pas de défendre vos
pions pas seulement au pied toujours
pour pour l'activité ça poussera plus de
prendre vos adversaires alors qu'est ce
qu'on va regarder tiens emmanuel
guignard commence une partie avec les
noirs on retrouve en mairie d'och avec
les blancs emmanuel rivière qui joue un
petit système avec deux fois en femme
kate au csd 5
ça évite un peu les grands débats
théoriques moi j'ai aussi joué genre de
truc d'ailleurs galles alliés qui à
terme davies et l5 pour l'instant de ne
pas pas de l'espace aux blancs mais bien
sûr on va essayé de miner le centre
abandonnés soit par ces cinq soit par m6
le genre on joue plutôt très vite
l'ouverture
alors la syrie losc a failli bad and the
beast apparemment on n'a pas besoin de
partis n'essaiera de monsieur peut-être
set the beast un petit peu plus tard du
s'inscrira en retard alors qu'ariane 5
qui est assez logique mais ici on va le
fou et f2 avec les blancs sont des
malins et le fou angers castres retrouve
un peu en danger donc il devra
s'échanger sur le cavalier une problème
ici c'est que les blancs voire beaucoup
d espace pour jouer h3g 4 ou chasser les
pièces noires gagner des tempos c'est
important et c'est l'info qui réagissent
très de sinon ça va être un peu un
rouleau compresseur sur leurs droits
même si on a des petits rois ne faut pas
avoir peur d'envoyer des pions
gecas toujours un bon coup c'est pas
vous que je vais la prendre il a reculé
il faut lancer assez bizarre parce que
de toute façon à mon dos ni de droit il
devrait approcher ce cas l'alliance fou
peut pas sortir du plateau n'a pas le
droit
du coup à part si le sacrifier sur
jacques à douala finalement qu'il a
juste perdu un temps fou à reculer le
fou pour manger le cavalier manu un
cavalier supérieur à une dame
après il ya plus beaucoup de torts à la
banlieue on n'est pas loin de cette
vérité là le four chanteur fou et très
très fort cavalier c'est vraiment la
pièce qui apporte le plus de poids des
mauvaises surprises
elle est passée aux aveux cette zone est
selon moi les c'est sale c'est le raf
du coup j'ai qu'a été jouée elle va très
bien vu maintenant l'idée tout
simplement on va pouvoir enchaîner on va
jouer à cinq unités typique aussi donc
la m5 savons tous que notre plongée
qu'attaquer être parfois de leroy j'ai
deux tours h
on a ce luxe parce qu'on a beaucoup plus
d espace de monter une attaque dans la
colonne h
et pourquoi pas viser la cad achète la
m5 est vraiment indispensable voilà
et je donne pas cher de la peau de ma
nuit ici le canard en colère qui se fait
inspecter avec les banques
numa numa nul alors est-ce qui peut
trouver des ressorts g5
je pense qu'il avait en tête façon à a
tenté ce coup m6 se crée un petit peu
une prison pour cavaliers ici est une
prison pour vous taxez pièces sont pour
beaucoup de bars il sera activé si jouer
même si c'est un jour ça terrible il y
aura eu 6 et la voilà bat greta qui
continue le plan c'est très bien joué
voilà c'est exactement ce qui se passe
en plus la justice on réfléchit même pas
honte on peut jouer un coup comme ça on
est vraiment très heureux a écrit un
petit enclos là c'est le cavalier
sortira plus jamais cette écurie si vous
regardez juste il est piégé par ses
propres pièces et le fou c'est pareil
donc une certaine façon ici les noyaux
avec deux pièces de moi sachant qu'ils
ont même pas développé sa encore bien
que les bons une suite ou même sur la
colonne âge par exemple
normalement le roi survivra pas parce
que pareil là beaucoup pas à s'échapper
le pion aux 6-8 monstrueux donc ici oui
cette période de crise n'était pas
nécessaire juste tout mettre sur la
colonne âge c'était encore plus simple
mais normalement c'est très facile pour
les blondes
alors il va les manger sous et même très
moche mais ils défendent est un petit
peu le roi on voit qu'en désespoir de
cause il est allé je sors même pièce sur
des cases parce que pour manger juste
pour casser le centre de
mais là c'est vraiment la torture à la
dame sans fil 3 à 8 mai prise
complètement le cavalier 17 ne
m'intéresse pas cet endroit que je
visais maintenant il ya des matches 8
matin d'un coup les cavaliers qui
bloguent fils avant le roi plus qu'autre
chose donc la fia durer le suspense en
anglais dès qu elle peut provoquer la
mort donc voilà il abattait sur
l'échiquier bombe à manu yade est
clairement difficile manu ça arrive
alors qu' on va aller voir et on a barh
variable contre cyril ou un peu macho
vient de se finir ces barbaries qu'à
gagner allez peut-être on a un match
intéressant c'est encore une finale
c'est terminé j'essaie de tomber sur une
partie qui joue écrit nice qui fait
respecter son rang ici ok on n'est pas
les voir aller là on a deux joueurs
finale qu'à l'allier tient entre bruno
et béni me axelle jeu là le charisme est
plus difficile à jouer
les plus tueur a calculé et ici pas
facile à évaluer cette position parce
que les pions blancs sont plus avancées
de ce côté là donc si jamais il a des
pouvoirs qui tombe il ira dame très vite
mais toi même c'est que le cavaly est
très mal passée pour attaquer bessette
que la case la plus dure à atteindre
pour un cavalier c'est une case qui est
adjacente à lui d'un point de vue
horizontal ou vertical les cases au
décollage il y avait facilement et donc
du coup de des stats il avait beaucoup
parlent trop un chemin pour attaquer
baisse est donc les blancs ils sont
partis pour congés une option de la dame
noire l'union de la droite
voilà il ya cavaliers moi j'aurais été
prendre celui ci puisque là le petit roi
il va couvrir très très vite
mais le droit à chaud aussi donc je
pense qu'il sait tout peut se produire
très difficile à évaluer savoir si un
des deux joueurs est mieux d'être fair
d'art en même temps sauf quelqu'un qui
arrive avant avec les noix juste le
droit de réfléchir ligne acsel à 30
secondes et c'est dans ce genre de
position c'est un peu dommage c'est tout
le tempo et quand tu arrives tu te rends
compte que ben a juste eu cours un tout
petit peu moins vite et que c'est la
particularité des pionniers du roi chez
quelqu'un qui va à dame et d'en
contrôler la casse des promotions
d'adversaires annoncé le pion bay qui
court plus vite que le son c'est à sept
joueurs qui sont de véritables athlètes
ils font ça très court dans chaque
couloir chacun leur tour
mais bruno apparemment est beaucoup plus
véloce
alors on va passer la technique pour
gagner serait bien qu'ils rahmani son
cavalier il a juste à manger wahaha
il contre la casse de promotion ok ça se
doit gagner aussi les contrôles mais
c'était quand même plus facile de projet
ce cavalier à très basse kabylie peut
pas sortir les coincer et à malte en un
coup d'oeil b2 qui l'a raté attention à
pas trop s'embrouiller les pinceaux
quand même que ça fait beaucoup de gain
évident raté on sait jamais cette
fourchette est vite arrivé alors il
prend son temps pour unir pour passe
trombe est cette fois-ci roi de 2 me
semble le sort de nos coûts très prudent
nous défendre cavaliers ya pas de
fourchette une brune chez petite frayeur
en ratant à matin ratant la pièce
entreprises anciens pas se mettre trop
bas le temps 5 secondes
ce cas là serait triste d'être
déconnecté pour joindre un peu bizarre
il donne son cavalier je sens l'accident
a aidé dans cette partie donc en battant
d'un coup d'objets mais ce qui va avoir
avec une seconde voilà il a perdu autant
il n'a pas indiqué complètement ici
pourrait donc je sais pas si c'est parce
pour garder sa partie
mais là c'est dommage avec une dame de
plus il avait trente secondes au départ
moi je trouve très souvent les choix se
compliquer la vie
vraiment je vais des coûts plus simple
peut-être un peu de lag ne sais pas
cette fois atteinte à la guerre ok mais
bailliage silva suis un peu le title
vous avez pu voir que un peu la
catastrophe niveau là aujourd'hui c'est
la peine mieux mais c'est possible que
les deux petits résidus
alors on va voir qu'est ce qu'on regarde
[Musique]
ce qu'on a pas vu encore peut-être
s'intéresser à cette partie ça commence
juste très bien entre lucien 2007 les
globe trotteurs globe trotters baby ski
et pas le dernier à soupçonner ses
adversaires à taller vu ma tante plus
beau cadeau a été assez dur sur écoute
archi 30 secondes a juste eu peu de
pouvoir qui est génial il a perdu comme
ça contre contre un important pouvoir
mondial à cause du lag et tout le title
tu es dedans pls kosslick donc salut
bidouille mais vraiment trop joueurs
connectés en même temps parfois ça crée
des problèmes
alors qu'est ce que ça donne cette
partie latéraux que posait donc
logiquement on devrait voir quand même
pas mal d'attac lé placement sont un peu
bizarres vos places c'est à dire
qu'elles sont devant leur roi donc les
risques avec les noirs de perte de tempo
sur les coups de pieds adverses
la socialite très intéressant dans la
grande diagonale qui était 5e
non je voulais on va taxer cette on
attaque la dame menace f4 qui sera une
fourchette playa juste trop de menaces
et donc globe trotter il va y laisser
des plumes et la f4 tout simplement
assez dommage ce trouble de côté il y
avait une fourchette d'un seul coup ça
c'est un coût qui est vraiment très très
dommage de manger ce cavalier
vous avez un fou qui est monstrueux dans
une grande diagonale extrêmement
puissant de pièces data qui va viser g7
et vous le donner en plus c'est aussi le
défenseur de notre pas juste contre un
cavalier qui va être potentiellement
remplacer par un autre cavalier
oui c'est tromper avec noah il avait dû
reprendre comme ça pour garder la
colonne des fermes et il a pris de court
il a appris deux pions il créa xavier la
vis à vis quand c'est fatal qui permet
de gagner la dame donc ici c'est lucien
gagne la dame donc du coup pour globe
trotter c'est un petit peu la fin des
haricots
alors oui c'est de retrouver une partie
ce n'est pas décidé à inscrire docteur
on l'a vu dans le chatt d'été un peu
dégoûté d'avoir laissé échapper un gros
poisson
on va voir comment il se comporte avec
les grandes contre une kalach tient un
grand maître gims le lien est pareil ici
un site internet pour voir les
ouvertures détaillé la meilleur outil
pour les ouvertures généralement de
chasse bases sont là pour vous c'est pas
gratuit
j'ai passé 17 souviens juste pour les
ouvertures tu peux avoir des sites pour
une ouverture spécifiques selon laquelle
tu joues dans notre très générale
d'aller très bon site pour les parties
la chasse des b sur lequel une grosse
base de données de deux parties une fois
qu'il fait une grosse perf contre un
jour à plus de 60 points de plus que lui
c'est pas mal du tout c'est peut-être le
tueur sadique team 40 cents alors est ce
que ça donne ici série 9 qui a joué à
cinq mais une position assez calme pour
l'instant et noir qui manque un petit
peu d'espacé ici rien trop en bessin que
c'est bien joué
en fait là ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de la case des cartes pour nos cavaliers
on va certainement visé c'est ça ya un
trou c'est un très bel avant postes pour
celle ci il est protégé par un pion et
aucun pur adverse qui peut de chasse et
donc du coup c'est ce qu'on considère un
avant poste pour un cavalier
on a très envie d'y installer l'un des
deux ans puis cela dans ce cas là les
deux peuvent se défendre mutuellement
dont certains qui selon lui pourra être
remplacée par l'autre le pion c7 est
attaqué extrêmement faible et a priori
plus ou moins défendables beaucoup de
problèmes c'est pour cirer lab dans
cette position les plantes contre est
bien exploité leur avantage des espaces
halde alors ils jouent car il ya eu les
seuls coûts pour pour défendre c'est
simple mais maintenant tout simplement
cavaliers venus des quatres faire très
attention la dame se retrouvera vraiment
à l'étroit donc la poupée 7 semble au
relatif confort c'est pour donner un
petit peu derrière adam ascaron ferme
elle que l'acca de la casse s'est vite
de disponible donc ici maintenant avec
les plans d'un jeu extrêmement
harmonieux et deux fois en forme qui
toutes nos pièces super bien placé
accède tour qui paient pas grand chose
donc la difficulté une fois qu'on a
optimisé le patron de sépia sait comment
gagner une partie ça suffit pas que les
échecs sont en jeu si difficile et qu'on
peut très bien de jouer mais ensuite
réussir à convertir la conversion c'est
peut-être l'étape la plus difficile du
coup là je pense qu'il est assez juste
de continuer de prendre plus d espace d
un petit peu c'est lé latéral elle dame
les pièces rares sont aussi mobilisés
elles n'ont aucune solution est donc
maintenant le kadhafi qu'à trouver c'est
tout et de saint-just eux continué de
prendre plus d espace de créer un nouvel
avantage au centre en bout d'un peu
rouleau compresseur donc wild card
paraître très bien ici avec psy de jouer
cavalier c6
pourquoi pas être prendre du plomb qui
perd la casse pour l'une de ses pièces
mais il est en train de dire à l'accueil
est obligé de revenir en baby cooper
voit les deux cavaliers noirs qui sont
très mal placés
il qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à revenir
en jeu parce qu'ils sont dominés par les
par les options par leurs propres pions
parfois mais attention
l'avantagé 10 peuvent vite vite filé à
refouler cache pas trop qu'à valider le
reprendre de la tour du cavalier
la colonne à s'ouvre pour la tournoi
mais ça c'est pas antoine pour les
blancs fenêtre principale de damas est
de réussir à jouer ce cavalier à six
parce qu'il n'a pas d'autres cases mais
à 6 et le problème c'est que ces options
beckham sur un plan de défendre le pion
b4y restreint complètement le cavaly un
peu comme tout à l'heure d'aller d'une
partie où c'était manu je crois qu'elle
tombe qu'elle et ses cavaliers en prison
voilà c'est pareil ou c'est une prison
un peu plus ouverte et un peu plus de
liberté il a droit à une promenade par
jour ce cavalier entre d'éviter à 6 mais
c'est tout un petit peu de mal à
apprendre il est confiné en fait c'est
un peu comme dans ce cas là il illustre
très bien est ce qu'on est en train de
vivre elle veut pas sortir du périmètre
quoi il va deux cases plus loin mais pas
plus ans tu vas pas les tiens beaucoup
au roi a pas besoin du coup avec les
boys là il a tout à fait raison qu'il a
bloqué sa allèles dame est maintenant à
son jeu il oriente au centre et sur le
droit
donc il va essayer de pousser ses pions
de créer du jeu de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier
alors il reste quand même 40 milieu tel
crime donc si tu me lis ashton mais le
système est d'inscrire des 1,40 but de
faire quelques quartiers grand maître
gims ne veut pas la pression d'avoir
tous les projecteurs braqués sur lui
boukous prend on a fait craquer plus
d'un alors que cinq ici ce concours est
de voir c'est très bien je ne fais une
grosse partie kalach
on sent qu'il ya une très grande
compréhension positionnelle de ce qui se
passe là pris beaucoup de bonnes
décisions il a placé ses pièces sur les
bonnes cases
on va voir si elle pressé jusqu'au bout
alors l5 le problème ce qui est
peut-être la prise ici mon client kg ça
maintenant un coût qui peut être
intéressant c'est m6 mais vous calculez
parce que mon père notre cave à notre
fou sur échec peut faire un peu peur
mais on aura toujours rage et de
nombreux cavaliers on va la récupérer
parce que la dame
bref si sera attaquée elle aura aucune
case pour venir défendre le fonds a pris
le jeu est très simple vous j'ai deux
voilà il prend pas de risque et vers le
cloud 5 d'attention parce que si les
noirs arrivent à jouer m6 ensuite il en
train de craquer en surimpression est ce
que le problème c'est que y'a pus on
prend cavaliers qui attaquent la dame
même si on prend la tour alsace la dame
adverse pardo va pas griller de matériel
et le drame d ici c'est que l'option b 4
va tomber et donc qu'est ce qui se passe
mais ça y est le cavalier est sorti de
son ghetto maintenant on sait pas trop
comment il ya un tuyau d'arrivée en c2 à
une casse de la dame et donc il n'a pas
fallu grand-chose en et les blancs
perdre autant j'avais pas vu qu'il y
avait la pression autant ils ont très
bien joué pendant très longtemps
la difficulté va c'était pile le moment
de basculement d'être
écrasant positionnement a gagné
tactiquement gagner du matériel et c'est
là où le bât a blessé six rénove cette
fois ci qui sont quand même très bien
alors je le vois quel parti maître gims
le titre est frauduleux voyagez pas
champ de cette race est vrai que m avec
kim se mettre à guînes cbo je vois pas
de maître gims cas peut-être fini sa
partie on va lancer une partie commandes
juste avec chet f4 entre druzes eu 67
j'ai pas du tout regardé le classement
pour l'instant jeu comme jeter un oeil
c'est mon gré foley qui caracole en tête
avec dix sur dix barbarian est un petit
peu lâché avec avec 8 sur 9 derrière
d'un seul tic à 7 sur cette future est
pas très loin non plus mais même en
greffe au loyer rase dénoncé
moi alors cavaliers h4 tout de suite on
va s'emparer de la paire de fou ça c'est
plutôt une bonne chose pour les blancs
ouverture la commune âge c'est pas très
grave au pire on jouera je crois me
donnait sur vous faire petit rock bien
sûr pas terre peut s'y rendre tout de
suite ça ce serait dramatique les
clôtures âge que voilà ils nous écoutent
chef steph dans cette position bas ça
joue en tête un petit plus pour les
plantes grâce à la paire les foules et
blanc qui vont certainement moi si tu
peux 4 à un moment donné ça le centre
libéré leur fou de deux cases noires et
loire devrait plutôt penser pas sur ce
lit pas opté pour le courant et s'ils
veulent tenter une attaque un peu sur la
colonne h mais vous aussi subir l'assaut
normalement des blancs ou alors le petit
rock plus solide qu'elle approche
pleutre petit rock ou la pop
l'approchent grand seigneur accord on va
voir ce qu'il choisit ici druzes et
qu'un drapeau australien il a petit
monstre il du coup les cannes le
bienvenu
ça lui donne au barça des bretons du
monde pour t'habitues oblige ce qui est
des ouvertures justement nous c'est pas
du tout forcément obligatoire
ça dépend vraiment de ton niveau parce
que jusqu'à un certain point à toute
façon les gens connaissent pas trop à
théorie donc ça sert à rien d'avoir un
répertoire de connaître deux choses
parker est un bon dégage je regarde un
petit peu si j'ai envie je change va y
aller mollo sur les directives du coup
on s'intéresse à chester contre une
russe pendant lequel il ya le centre
pour les blancs et à la perte de
fouilles à la colonne verte ou plein
davantage oppositionnel surtout ce
qu'elle s'impose cette grande diagonale
n'empêche les droits dont rockets du
petit côté donc un bon avantage des
spasmes aussi pour les blancs mais
encore une fois c'est comme tout à
l'heure on a vu que c'était loin d'être
suffisant pour garantir ensuite la
concrétisation
victoire donc la question c'est où
reculait ce fou est ce qu'on voit dans
cette diagonale ou est-ce qu'on change
les options ici ont du sens
je pense un rôle dans looking est
mauvaise dans tous les cas on sera
toujours bien avec les blancs sativus
redirigée vers la f3 pourquoi pas avec
les noix je pense qu'il faut y aller
faut pas avoir peur faut balancer le
grand roque lauréats gâchis plus de 2000
c'est peut-être excessive on s'est
penché sur sur la théorie est à partir
de 1800 à 2100 un truc c'est bien de
regarder un peu des choses mais c'est
vraiment pas la priorité en tout cas au
moins jusqu'à 1600 vraiment je
conseillerais de quasiment pas regardé
le 1800 c'est un petit peu voilà le
vecteur ça commence à devenir
intéressant alors ils seront là ce matin
h 2 du coup le seul coup après plusieurs
chez n'importe quoi il ya peu 5 en fait
qui est peut-être mieux que j'ai trois
mais j'ai trois héroïnes ce qu'on
attaque l'adami l'aja même temps de
manger à trois ans pourra tranquillement
reculer notre foule des 5 c'est bien de
faire cette diagonale et du coup on
interrompt la liaison entre le fouet la
dame sur quasiment par la même occasion
de n'ouvre un peu notre fou et ses 4
c'est plutôt bien joué le chasser ce fou
qui nous embête est quand même par
annozero n'a donc il va certainement
revenir au c1 faire attention à bilbao
c5
il va se faire enfermer son fou c'est un
piège un petit pic le four à plus de
casque en fait il peut pas rester dans
cette diagonale à 3 je suis là pour
progresser jusqu'à 1800 et à vraiment
énormément show énormément de choses par
doit regarder principalement une fois
qu'on a gommé toutes les erreurs un peu
de base tactique perd plus de pièces en
sommes complètement n'arrive à calculer
ils ont deux trois coups sans se tromper
c'est vraiment là la compréhension la
stratégie on comprendre les plombs les
idées et positions ouvertes fermées les
structures de pions pourquoi elle
changer des pièces quand identifier les
pièces fortes les pièces faible trouver
les bonnes cases pour ses pièces
essayez de tir bala mon cavalier
j'aimerais bien battre ou 1,58 vous
cherchez le chemin
il ya énormément de choses hein je
t'aime aux riches énormément de choses à
essayer de comprendre d'un point de vue
stratégique
donc pour sabata des vidéos et à des
vidéos de parts et analysés qui avait
déjà fait plein qui sont intéressantes
des paralysés par des grands maîtres
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici pourquoi
habile a juste donné son cours et
d'écouté il abandonne alors je passe il
arrivé là juste buggé la nuit sont fous
emprise c'est dommage qu'ils aient une
bonne partie en chef d'oeuvre 4 sa vie
qui était en contrôle et j'allais juste
se mettre sur une case protéger puis
ensuite continué peut-être balancé à
simple pour mettre une pression sur
bessette le roi qu'il sait pas trop de
quel côté allait donc la passe
typiquement c'est bête frustrant de
perdre une partie comme ça alors on a
maugréé folique est toujours en tête et
la 11 sur 11 derrière ça revient un
petit peu malgré tout ce que je joue à
d'autres jeux alors j'adore tous les
jeux en général les jeux de stratégie
jeux vidéo pas tant que ça n'a pas trop
joué un peu à lol joueurs stades en
preuve une époque
sinon je suis joueur tous les jeux de
cartes et normes ou jouer au poker et
des jeux de manière générale le
stratégie mais pas qu un jeu d'action
qui peut réussir de rapidité
est ce que je vise le titre deux amis
pas vraiment parce qu'en fait je joue
assez peu un tournoi et j'ai jamais
vraiment appréhender les tchèques de
manière sérieuse n'ait jamais travaillé
chaque pour essayer de remonter le plus
haut possible donc je joue plus pour me
faire plaisir
si je deviens émis 11 ans des bonnes
perfs
tant mieux mais en tout cas je sais pas
un objectif en cash et en tournant le
cocaa germond fais les deux pour le coup
j'ai même été faire le 2 pt pendant la
belle époque
non il n'y a pas une grosse différence
entre alex verre entre amis et fm alex
personnes ça va vraiment dépendre du fmi
et du fn potentiellement mais on peut
dire qu'un joueur qui aime être fidèle
et gagne pas très loin il est proche des
2400 simard un coup de collier vraiment
je fais des tours noir c'est un objectif
a priori le titre de n y est pas est ce
vraiment pas inatteignable
j'aime c'est autre chose c'est quand
même vraiment pas aller beaucoup plus
difficile à atteindre
tellement de assurément plus de talent
et de
travail alors tiens tout en haut
bâti en cours entre le vieux et le cac a
donc tué du coup le jeu kaka ou tu eu
qui va l'emporter avec les doigts y
beaucoup de bataille d'avants ce juste
qu'il fasse attention impasse prendre
perpète un jour ou l'autre ex 3g si ce
n'était pas nécessaire on se devrait pas
poser problème ça vu maugrey fu live 10
ans bogdan volaille original puisque
finalement le toi tu n'as pas le nombre
derrière
est-ce qu'on peut affronter aux échecs
en petit frère le préciser la question
des bouchauds les possibles dans cette
chaise comme de faire des parties en
différé à fait dans les options je
connais pas du tout les gens d'eau
froide terra je n'ai pas entendu parler
encore c'est un jury yonne tu me dis
donc comme lol c'est un jeu qui est déjà
sortie et le gâchis qui va sortir ce
qu'on peut
monté en différé sur une chaise pour un
corps mais oui on peut que j'accepte de
quelques défis je lance pas 12000 parti
en même temps mais ça m'arrive de jouer
quelques parties ont différé n'hésite
pas sur des pierres j'accepterai salut
gens fous de la doudoune il est open le
jeu elle caché jetterai un oeil pour
voir ce que c'est alors je pas docteur
on serait pas là en train de trimer mais
j'en fume pour répondre à des questions
c'est normal d'avoir des moments de
stagnation aux échecs
c'est vraiment très standard de
progresser je parlais de mon cas
personnel j'ai pu très souvent avoir des
grosses progressions il y ait beaucoup
de points d'un coup en l'espace de six
mois par exemple il y ait 300 points et
ensuite pendant deux ans je restais un
petit peu à ce palier est à nouveau je
regagnais beaucoup de points très
souvent le fonctionnement c'est par
paliers et ensuite ils période de
stagnation
parce que c'est un joueur avec tellement
de complexité est tellement de choses à
un magazine et qu'il est normal de pause
entendent bloquer en fait on peut pas
avoir une progression moliner trop
difficile ans le pet comme la courbe
malheureusement de gens affectés
il ya toujours des un peu en escalier
plutôt à la progression des échecs et
maugrée folie ça fait combien de temps
que tu arrives pas à dépasser les 1850
comme essayent de trouver d'autres
partis en même temps que je réponds à
vos questions
alors j'ai aperçu cep de best party cas
montre de bourgeois tous les deux à
quasi entre 2300 et 2400 on a une finale
dans laquelle j'ai l'impression que le
fou dominent largement ce cavalier et en
plus il ya un flou très dangereux donc
ben ses marques dans cette position les
blancs pour l'instant tourne plus lors
ils peuvent leur perdre à tout moment on
le sent pas du tout ce pan le plus
justement du fait de la structure très
détérioré des plans surtout ce qu'avait
déjà extrêmement puissant l'a récupérée
par à 5 6 7 the beast qui normalement
devrait gagner alors ça fait longtemps
tu me dis ok mais tu joues pas si
régulière donc c'est là-bas
effectivement c'est bien sûr c'est bien
sûr d un des principal impératif pour
progresser il faut jouer ou rejouer
alors c'est pas le même membre est folle
elle je crois petit poney si son jumeau
caché celui qui est pas le bandeau sur
les yeux quatre îlots polynectar du coup
oui si tu joue pas beaucoup
c'est normal que tu stagne au risque de
1850 déjà entrés ou tu me parles de
chess comme un ce qu'il ya une
différence aussi ce qui est peut-être
plus facile de progresser sur internet
quand on devrait tout simplement parce
qu'on fait + 2 tours - comment on reste
concentrés en partie long capote masse
casting bonnes questions ont même je
suis pas sûr d'avoir vraiment la réponse
je pense qu'à dépens de gamme de pas mal
de
le facteur s'inquiète des joueurs qui
reste vissé sur leur chaise du début à
la fin
j'en fais pas parti je me balade
beaucoup pendant mes parties longues
jusqu'à un certain point pour moi ya
vraiment un moment de basculement d'une
partie rouge dans lequel je rentre
vraiment dans la partie d'une espèce
d'état un peu secondes dans lequel voilà
je suis inspiré par l'intérêt de la
position alors que pendant toute la
phase d'ouverture
je suis encore pas vraiment dans le truc
j'ai vraiment pour moi deux étapes un
jeu dans une partie classique
il ya aussi le côté facteur temps
débutait mal autant face compter un peu
obligé de rester concentré parce que tu
sais que tu as pas t'as pas le choix
et ouais lequel tout le temps debout
parfois ça peut être un défaut mais
après c'est aussi une question de
personnalité d'état d'esprit pour se
concentrer à des exercices de relaxation
qui peuvent aider deux fois plus peut
être faire certains joueurs avant le
parti pas forcément de secrets pour la
concentration mais la relaxation peut
jouer ça dépend aussi forcément en fait
dans sa vie personnelle
si je joue une partie à dix mille soucis
en tête battre à bukama concentré si l
inverse tués dans une période serait
apaisée
je pense sera plus facile de se mettre
en mode échec et de jouer la partie est
de réussir à faire les choses bien que
dès l'instant de son nez dans domaine du
mental c'est difficile de se déconnecter
complètement de qui ont des montants
division et je fais pas assez se
concentrer sur notre jeu parce que nos
pensées on ne peut pas les contrôler
elles vont être viège et dans une partie
on pense à mille choses n'ont souvent
aucun rapport avec les échecs
j'imagine que c'est un peu votre cave
aux sciences vous faites un peu de
partir en ville c'est différent parce
qu'on n'a pas le temps par unité ultra
stressée le futur alors là c'est souvent
dans ces cas-là contre blog contre un
joueur en particulier contre un type
d'elliot dès l'aube à redon j'ai
néanmoins valoir une victoire dakar hier
on va dire qui peut être synonyme un
petit peu de déclencheur les prises de
conscience que finalement contre ces
joueurs là tu as tes chansons tu as pas
avoir peur de passer dans un état
d'esprit plus positif mais souvent c'est
vraiment une victoire qui va te donner
la confiance même une nulle cas une
bonne partie à te permets de dire ok en
fait j'en suis capable et donc j'espère
que tu auras ce déclic branché que ça
pouvait marcher comme ça par exemple
quand j'étais petit je faisais un
tournoi rapier 2 en gros il y avait
toujours deux joueurs qu'ils pouvaient
gagner c'était un mec sait pas que les
classes et 2000 moi j'étais encore petit
mais donc j'avais à 1800 mais je
finissais toujours deuxième batterie
tout le temps dès l'instant que le match
une fois ensuite je me suis mis à le
battre à chaque fois je les y ai reçu
dix fois de suite c'est purement
psychologique et les gect - jeu
extrêmement psychologique et donc c'est
normal d'avoir des fois des blocages au
passage cette finale dames contre toi
gagnon alors c'est très difficile très
difficile en pratique avec 20 secondes
pour les deux joueurs de progresser on
va voir s'il y arrive mais c'est très
bien petit poney du coup tu sais ce que
j'écrivais effectivement h
peut-être pas la patience nécessaire
pour les parts que commencer est ce que
tu as fait un peu des tournants rapide
déjà un tournoi sur une journée tu fais
entre 7 end à proust du 15 minutes où
divers minutes de jasmin et tabac dans
la partie c'est vrai que la partie bah
oui ce goût tout caractère ça peut juste
en berbère ou chine mais commence par
essayer cette des rapides sur une
journée l'ambiance sur les tournois
seront assez sympa l'appelant de prix de
l'eau est ce un bon compromis entre les
blitz et la partie en plus tu vas courir
petit poney a compté parti baas penser
une très très bonne habitude savent
toute façon activité sportive au plus
haut niveau il est indispensable et au
delà de couvrir même ne serait-ce que se
promener se joue en un rituel où les
joueurs avant un trailer partie dans les
matchs de championnat du monde très
souvent très souvent on assiste à ces
balades et ce conseil en fait cardiaque
et je me rappelle qu'ils se baladaient
une heure après c'est parti golkar scène
avec ce soupçon seconde ans pour des
périls pour s'aérer le cerveau c'est
nécessaire en fait sinon ça roule
surchauffe et celle des basques qui me
dit que ça lac trop à moi je suis pas
affecté par le lag
je sais je sais que ça dépend vraiment
malheureusement de vous être des
connexions et que depuis le confinement
tweet chagan pas que twitch ailleurs des
petites mesures qui font que le flux
internet peut être un peu plus compliqué
chez certains et on la crypte un qui
revient très fort à quatre points de
mauvais poil alors c'est qu'on peut
trouver une partie de l'un des deux qui
sont en train de jouer
pour l'instant je ne vois pas reste une
petite vingtaine de minutes donc tout
est possible on va partir sur autre
chose du coup tempier alors ça ça vient
de se terminer
je vais rechange est à la bourre et fola
et ça y est tu allais blandan qu'elle
est noire pardon entre eux hugo il ya un
gros écart et l'homme on a vu dans ces
dérives ya souvent des surprises vers la
position
la très très bordélique esquissé pas
nous manque des pièces ici au aux
joueurs blancs il en banque ou au moins
une est un cavalier de moins or
certaines étapes de courage mais le
problème c'est que là aussi du c6 du fou
aussi si si je comprends pas toute cette
position est très bizarre parce que les
coups un petit peu pierre picca après
l'échangé dame
j'ai l'impression que les blancs vous
même réussi à récupérer leurs pièces
diamant recours sur ce clou rage madame
l6 paraître une décision peut-être pas
hyper tracy la part de bourgueil folle
alors après il doit être toujours bien
mais là c est normal tu prennes sont
hors ue puisque c'est très complexe et
plein de choses à calculer peut aussi
voir les prisons 24 ce que ça donne
salut public a tort
et oui alex verse
effectivement ça m'étonne pas et que des
articles de ce type et que je te parle
en fait de plus déclaré qu'effectivement
les joueurs allaient à la salle de
sports chaque fois qu'il y aura un jour
de repos
c'est devenu maintenant la norme peut
attendre d'eux de faire ça c'était
moindre ace a du temps par exemple de
crâne big ben à topalov mood sa superbe
je pense que ces joueurs-là était un peu
moins précautionneux sur tout ce qui
touchait à la condition physique et
jacques davantage maintenant le côté à
mon sport et je pense que caressait d'un
petit peu aussi participé à ça avec le
champion du monde et qui est quand même
réputée pour être très sportif on voit
tout le temps avec un ballon de foot de
basket dans la khl est enfin dès qu'il a
un jour de repos dans un top 3 la plein
de photos ici est mitraillé en train de
faire du sport c'est que c'est un
passionné de sport j'ai un petit peu
peut-être lancé cette mode et les aux
joueurs du top niveau l'eau suffit alors
de manière pour certains moins naturel
est les forces un petit peu ça se sent
mais au moins ils font l'effort maxime
je sais que l'époque il essayait de pas
mal pas mal courir faire souvent de
jogging alors des fois comme calendrier
surchargé que c'est un peu compliqué
castrophe où ils cassent pas porter un
trait curseur ça c'est vrai frank zappa
il s'était aussi pour ça qu'il était
aussi fort et qui mette une telle
pression psychologique sur ses
adversaires parce qu'il y avait ce côté
condition physique ingrat vous dis que
je pense n'avait pas ramené qui a eu
beaucoup de soucis de santé en plus
durant sa carrière
donc adieu faire avec ça et la capote
masqué faire une partie oui à l'occasion
oui sans problème
pas maintenant parce que je
je commande d'un autre monde haut débit
n'hésite pas à mlle d'officiel du coup
dans cette position on voit qu'avec les
plans il s'en est bien sorti parce que
quand on arrivait était complètement
foutu avec une pièce d'un mois il a
récupéré - bref au laïka pas été très
précis et à cette finale du coup avec
cette perte du fou mutuelle
c'est une perte de tours aussi ou bien à
cannes un léger avantage structurel pour
les noix l'option c2 qui est faible même
si m6 est un peu faible aussi le roi
qu'à un peu plus de mal à s'activer
mais jusqu'à demain mois de rahma l'on
va dire pour pour les blancs étant donné
le vertueux que c'était très mal passé a
priori donc hugo qui malgré ses 700
points de moins ils se battraient bien
et met la pression sur le leader alors
vallier allie donc les styles des
joueurs ils sont très variables
effectivement ça va dépendre si beaucoup
d époque c'est-à-dire il ya les joueurs
actuels et ceux ceux qui ont pris leur
retraite donc baccarat scène pour
commencer par le meilleur c'est vraiment
le style universel
là c'est difficile de lui en attribuer
un de précis parce qu'il est bon tout
simplement les bons calculs et les bons
évidemment en finale en stratégie en
tactique est bien meilleur en ouverture
que les gens pour elle suppose et aussi
en fait l'étude que pendant assez
longtemps et je vais pas trop les
grandes lignes carrées scène mais il a
toujours des petites idées et des
petites idées qu'il a évidemment bien
travaillé avec ce goût dorment seul et
donc ça lui permet d'être à l'aise dans
les positions donc c'est un joueur va
tellement complet mais sa marque de
fabrique c'est quand même le côté de
mettre la pression jusqu'au bout ses
airs de
ne jamais vouloir faire de l'an fait da
partir de rien être capable de petit à
petit fissurait la carapace de son
adversaire prêt parmi les candidats on a
maxime qui va excellente calcul
peut-être deux meilleurs au monde en
calcul en tout cas un des tous meilleurs
qui est très très bon au final aussi un
maxime je trouve le point fait de maxime
c'est un peu les ouvertures
c'est un des seuls joueurs à ce niveau
là qui a un répertoire très stéréotypé
joue un coup toujours la même chose
du coup il est bien sûr brillant sur sa
nage nord mais globalement dernier avant
tout cas il a du mal à obtenir quelque
chose de ces ouvertures même si c'est
aux candidats c'était pas trop mal passé
là dessus d'un petit peu du mal donc
là-dessus et c'est quand même aussi un
point plutôt d'attaquants maxima joueurs
disent n'applique en tout cas jamais de
chercher la défense passe il m'est
toujours plein de ressources je
retrouvais une idée proposer un problème
concret j'ai plus loin des greenshows
qui disait pour battre maxime faut le
battre 10 fois dans une partie dans le
sens où bailly ont un avantage décisif
on pense que l'autre est quasiment prêt
à abandonner le maxi me trouve toujours
des ressources toujours toujours dans
les odeurs a great chaud par exemple
c'est vraiment un puriste c'est à dire
que j'ai tellement perfectionniste que
ça lui joue des tours ça l'empêchent de
prendre des décisions parfois il peut
passer 45 minutes pour choisir quel tour
mais 31 la tour e ou la tour c est donc
c'est un joueur qui a du mal à prendre
de décision donc ça va ça va être dans
l'excès qu'il ya une compréhension du
jeu stratégie qui est exceptionnel mais
green shoots il manque un peu le côté de
pratiques comme par exemple des joueurs
comme del po bien chiluba kaburaki sont
des joueurs très pratique on côté ils
sont capables de jouer de jouer vite
mettre la pression d'avancer leurs
adversaires ils cherchent pas forcément
toujours le meilleur
l'aspect plus humain - - garde
sectionnistes
alors le pilote dont je vous conseille
pas tu as posé la question mais oui ch
ont progressé ça dépend le pilote situe
à un certain niveau déjà ça peut t'aider
un peu dans les acteurs d'avoir acquérir
de meilleurs réflexes
mais pour ça autant faire des listes
parce qu'en biais de ce quand même
normal qu'on sera un peu plus propre une
bien terne c'est plus quelque chose pour
s'amuser et ça te fait pas progresser en
blitz tu peux davantage tester c'étaient
des choses quand même un minimum de
temps pour se connecter à un pc pas que
bbc un lag
dites-moi priori a pas eu d'autres
retours en ce sens qu'il reste 10
minutes et on a crypte table ça y est
telle qu'à dépasser maugrée fu live donc
pourtant il avait beaucoup d'avancé à
montgueux la folie ce que je pourrais
trouver cryptage justement ne le voit
pas du coup on va repartir sur une
nouvelle folie dans ce cas comme la
victoire je suis entre les deux mondes
révolte jouer contre un joueur suisse
contre renom qui est glacée 900 il ya
quand même un très gros écarts et on va
voir comment cet écart s'exprime sur
l'échiquier devant simon rythme est
capable mais très vite
et oui tu as raison à bord et voilà une
petite chatte
du coup pour progresser vraiment intérêt
à jouer en 10 ou 20 minutes pour
réfléchir davantage sinon c'est plus du
réflexe hambli du coup par coup
en fait dès l'instant où j'ai pas encore
suffisamment sûr de toi ont joué pour me
sens trompé le blitz bas ça fait
progresser un petit peu platon
d'induction mais qui manque en faire
trop d'erreurs
qui joue le lenglen en ouverture
principal c'est une bonne question
alors j'ai vraiment pas un expert de
l'ong laisse moi c'est quelque chose que
je n'ai jamais joué
pichot anglaise je pense que j'ai déjà
remis qu'à adams parce qu'il est anglais
et je crois que c'était vraiment un
bijou encore un petit peu moins mais il
était un très haut niveau pendant
longtemps un très bon joueur dont blaise
adam doit pouvoir un peu regardez c'est
parti si je dis pas de bêtises et après
il ya plein de joueurs qui jouent
parfois lent play c'est à dire je vous
dis des quatre cavaliers f3 est parfois
assez calmes pour surprendre car cette
ça lui arrive de loi anglaise aronian il
joue parfois longues l'aise dans les
joueurs du top niveau
je sais pas trop qui doit être d'autres
l'ajout guiry de temps en temps
certainement well alex personnes ont
repéré la sarabande avantage elles
veulent la joue beaucoup dit poupine à
toi tu m' troll
nb je me souviens avoir vu le jour l
anglaise vraiment peut-être que de
manière exceptionnelle pour une prépa
mais je pense pas que ça soit marque de
fabrique a priori rien en fait à ce
niveau là la plupart des joueurs presque
tous deux temps en temps faites pour
comprendre le jeu c'est bien de être
capable en tout cas un tel niveau de
jouer le 4 et des cats 7 ouvre sur des
positions vraiment différente
donc oui c'est ça enrichit grandes
ventes et perspectives
les a's et ou non et exigent un système
de l'ombre est l anglaise vous pourrez
s'y tromper mais c'est très différent
pour le coup ce pas du tout les mêmes
plans et les mêmes 10 heures
couché perdu de cette partie mauvais
fallen ont été complètement gagnant mais
la mauvaise nouvelle puisqu'il perd pas
mal de temps joue plus vite après son
adversaire il a bien raison il joue
contre un fort genre il n'a pas ce
concept chambre certainement il prend
son temps et c'est de se défendre au
mieux et du coup ça lui empêche de à
regret de marquer le point très vite
fait il aura qu'une autre partie
derrière pour attraper cristal salut
cherokee chess ont fait une robe du
béton aux fleurs le gaffeur que la
grande objectivement d'après les
versions l'ordi c'est le pire qu un g4
tout de suite les doigts après de l'
avantage il faut que tu te détache le la
psychologie c'est olivier a bloqué huit
ans que je suis bête et la ferrage
franchement du pseudo ok mais
effectivement tu as raison frank zappa y
en a plein qui justement
finalement quels que soient leur
répertoire de base ou juste jouer des
cas extrait pour se frotter à l'anglais
ça vaccine pas ce qu'on voit qu'il est
vraiment un peu pâle en plage qui
n'importe quoi à la grande fête de
maxime pasqua qu'il est un petit peu
fébrile dessus et non non c'est encore
pas du tout quand les candidats
reprendront du coup au classement c'est
toujours pareil cryptée à la 3 points
d'avancé sur moreno l'aï donc crypte
talent qui est parti pour gagner
barbarian et troisième ville antique
loin alors qu'est ce qu'on va regarder
finir papa cryptage tempe il alors
dense et intéressant qui commence entre
celles de base avec les bleus et paquito
alors c'est pas lui qui n'ont plus
reprendront les candidats sur la ligne
officielle c'est avec les mêmes joueurs
qui on veut la première moitié mais
radjabov est il très mécontents il a
parlé de prendre un avocat il ya
sûrement pour suivre la fidh
il va tout prix à traire intégrés dont
pour loire que ça reprenne à 0 donc là
on est parti pour un grand marasme
juridique je pense mais attendez que la
moitié des partie était jouée je fais
mais assez optimiste sur le fait que
reprendre avec les mêmes dans la même
situation
dans tous les cas trois sont sûrs par
des personnes s'estimant lésé quelle que
soit la décision finale
alors du coup j'ai menacé d'observer
noah ici comme ça instinctivement j'ai
tout fait sans prise de chaque côté il
va devoir reprendre des 4 il n'a pas le
choix tous avec le cavalier je dirais
regarder quand même ce qu'on fout ouais
et à la fin de la vente il ya ces deux
qui va tomber et prendre les quatre
points des quatre puis on prend ces deux
irait noir on peine d'une paire de fou
même si pour l'instant celui ci un peu
embêtante pointe sur g7 alors il a pris
en dessin qui n'a pas voulu manger ces
deux je pense c'est dommage une erreur
que ton c devraient être posés des
blancs des problèmes le plan quand même
d'un point de vue pratique et des fous
pkt chèque qui sera arrivé en foule et 4
pas du tout qui peut faire le beau jeu
mais ça marche pas du tout assez le
danger de faire un coup artificielle
décoratives c'est bien pour table c'est
à pisser le papier peint de la chambre
la foulée 4 mai par contre
dans les faits très mauvais ça ne sert à
rien ça menace rien et al'inverse avec
les bleus il a bougé j'ai cède garnd en
attaquant la tour donc se fout en fait
ça va se retrouver en l'air dans plein
de variantes parce que la dame le
défendent est donc avec les blancs gelé
l'europe justement j'ai une fois ici et
le regagner une pièce donc celle qui
s'est montrée je donnerai religion est
ce que je trouve que radjabov a raison
bah oui et non franchement radjabov je
comprends je comprends très bien
il ya les côtés je pense que le tournoi
a effectivement comme beaucoup auraient
dû jamais desmarais qui a priori n'a
jamais été ouvert au dialogue avec la
fidh qui va un petit peu dit bah tant
pis pour toi donc plus donc je comprends
très bien qui s'estime lésé a priori
c'était quand même très bien préparés à
l'écart yakine dobbin gaz je suis chez
l'homme je crois qu'il avait fait un
gros travail ils étaient motivés l'a pas
laissé jouer alors qu'il avait gagné le
bras ouvert à la solution d'être de me
voir dans l'absolu dans le sens où c'est
avec maxime mérite sa place un jeu très
content du maxsym bijoux et elle aurait
du sens mais un programme seti lui la
moitié de jouer à la vie joueurs donc à
partir de là on commença à neuf aurait
pas grand sens en fait il qu'aucune
solution pourrait de sens et celle des
baisses qui c'était ma tête
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici il a
complètement
on peut être mon crack cette partie
revenir à pendage justement c'était
interdit je vous ai tous b45 on va
vraiment pas très pas très utile en
réalité assez que du coup juste l'idée
c'était jiabao question match je le
tiens évidemment des cadres elle sera
très puissante et centralisée sauf que à
cette bête élevée raison il a juste
manger chez cet échange des formes ou
fou et j'attaque la tour
la tour à bouger là pour une raison un
port a connu sept the beast juste buggé
un petit peu il obtient de manger b4
elle est juste à manger b4 la dame s'est
fondée la même pièce de plus la partie
était terminée
donc c'est un petit peu incompréhensible
arias 30 secondes je sais pas
au classement du coup ça dit quoi crépy
talent est toujours devant avec trois
points d'avancé congrès fois lie à la
cire en train de jouer pour créer
l'exploit je ne vois pas
quoique c'est trop tard si en train de
jouer comme cyril ou mais en huit
secondes
il aura du mal à y ait cette partie
sèche et houphouet et puisque tu avais
après prison j'essaie de tout faire
et oui c'est la petite nul kaka c'est à
la série à bourghelles volailler duc au
cryptage a fait une grosse bouteille je
pense pas que la fille des rétro pédaler
lance le tournoi n'a fait le cas chez
barrault paquito et a fini sur une belle
perf cinquième du coup spammeurs et
ayabe xxxl pas réussi son objectif plus
qu'aux dommages
vous êtes 600 pompiers de pont sainte
anne donc si on avait voulu le faire
exprès n'aurait pas réussi donc bravo à
tous
cette difficile 1300 points d'eau des
cas effectivement c'est compliqué mais
on a vu quelques victoires peut-être à
800 points elo d'écart je l'étais plus
il y aura une revanche à prendre quelle
contre paquito demain et pour clôturer
avec le sujet de les candidats va
écouter santé qu'on aura des infos vous
l'éteindra mais étant donné la situation
je pense que c'est pas près d'arriver
ce dos et robin robin comme robin des
bois retirer s'ils réussissent side ses
marques et je pense sur le stream pouvez
le voir juste en dessous les plus gros
sont les déclarations de rajhi disons
qu'il n'était pas sûr de jouer en fait
rage elle s'est défendue lui en
affirmant que pendant la coupe du monde
on va dire un petit peu ça sa façon de
répondre aux interviews
comme quoi il n'est pas très motivée par
le trois des candidats c'était juste un
peu de second degré bompas porter la
poisse et que en azerbaïdjan nous et ça
couramment vous savez c'est à ça un peu
limite ce pas un peu tendancieux on va
dire cette interprétation mais vous dans
tous les cas peu importe dans l'absolu
il a gagné le droit de jouer il s'est
préparé pour le tournoi donc sa
motivation real ya que lui qui la
connaît au final on peut pas vraiment
présager on n'est pas dans sa tête car
en scène par exemple je sais que on a pu
voir douter fortement de la motivation
de radjabov mes achats box et fermement
défendu la tuer voilà du coup va
clôturer ce stream là dessus moi je vous
retrouve demain à 13h même rendez vous
et le soir il y aura quelques pour la
reine la fédération française d'échecs
parce qu'on truc encore un peu plus gros
donc quand il se retirer c'est du second
degré peut-être merci a tous fait une
bonne journée et je vous dis à très vite
à dos noir est ce soir je sais pas trop
si on a quelque chose de flou demain ces
trésors aussi et d'abord un sport ça
doit être à 20h 20h30 mais je vous le
dirai demain formation voilà